how's the game resumes pure it's time
for another favor lesson session who's
gonna be fabulous in this day only time
will tell I think it's time for Kevin
Bacon to become a bacon a Kevin Bacon
that such a great picture you take a
little bacon and you put it right in
your net Joel you got to do really a lot
of people ask how do you Photoshop hits
and really I just put bacon on people's
faces the rest really does itself
[Music]
all right then Kevin Bacon everyone
Kevin Bacon Kevin is a baby now Kevin
Bacon why do you have to say about your
hair candy bacon you want to make some
bacon Kevin Bacon because he's a bacon
mmm I wonder what I will have for lunch
today I will have some Kevin Bacon with
some Kevin Bacon with Kevin Bacon own a
cabin bacon [ __ ] that was too far I'm
sorry Kevin Bacon I want I want his eyes
to like Sully let's see if we can find
Kevin Bacon on Twitter hi here is you as
bacon please rate one to ten of how
family also you're welcome what the hell
fits you need help do you wanna give me
nightmares don't you think that's a bit
far what we're talking about at least
it's better than a potato Beyonce and a
bulldog you see thumbnail this is beyond
shut up shut up shut up - 9 - 9 Oh
didn't think so you know what I got an
idea let's take one direction and 5
sauce and do a face whap so its face
will go on Harry's face alright that's
done yeah this guy will go on Nick Zayn
yeah see I know the names
I'm not just some hypocrite fangirl and
then this lad but he well yeah hello
there we go done I might keep I might
actually you know what I feel a little
frisky I might keep them out for that
one cuz it looks so good
that actually fantastic okay I'll keep
the mouth it'll be like a hi hi sorry
but I ran out of faces you get to be
slender man or Voldemort yeah he gets to
be Voldemort what alright let's let's
fine-tune this genius idea
i-i'll keep Micah's mouth because damn
[Music]
so sometimes I just take stuff and I go
too far with it and then we have stuff
like this and my brain should just turn
itself off I'm just really tired and
then I come up with weird [ __ ] and I
don't even know that's let's hear the
cry of a million fire girls or the
laughter I hope they understand the joke
I just love Immortal event I'm so tired
that I didn't think oh my god absolutely
insane I would bang them all can I get
this as a poster well yeah I'll sign it
I'll make sure me and Voldemort signs it
that's too far dude too far what all
right things are like this come on
they're pretty oh my god I wish this is
actually a band that we do she recovers
and have a Harry Potter references in
every definitely don't have a life of
thanks we have time for one more because
I'm oh god do I need to finalize this no
I don't her tits looks like a [ __ ]
elephants like I what that's okay I
guess I swear to god sometimes these
just make themselves oh god don't zoom
in on the Tatas I think we're that eye
it's way hotter than before it's
supposed to freak you out but I'm like
oh damn
but it's good stuff
oh god I didn't realize you had that
little thing there but I am feeling
violated just looking at that oh my god
that's the next one place Irie on the
ground a Jesus I thought she was a dolt
what is this whole decision
what happens if ariana grande meets a
banana
let's ask ourself that and see what
happens
the thing with the phase of banana phase
is like how do you how does this how do
you have it like do make it thin or do
you make it yeah all right that's our
banana face let's make it happen baby
[Music]
there's our ariana burning it my god
that the noses really didn't work there
I don't even know what let's been head
over that [ __ ]
I never that's gonna catch up this is
the product of my night you're taking it
too far
why take it - what are you talking about
do you not know me by now alright you
know what we're gonna end it there it's
been it's been great I had a super
looming so I'm sorry if this video is
really dumb and maybe you're right maybe
I am taking it too far
but anyway what are you gonna do go I
don't even like um you know watching
hits the sky Cumbre today and I'm gonna
get some [ __ ] sleep so I'll see you
sales and press